Тенета для вітру заввишки 206 метрів.
Ці турбіни у федеральній землі Гессен в центральній частині Німеччини
забезпечують електроенергією тисячі домогосподарств.
Їх побудувало підприємство, яким керує Ганс-Петер Франк.
Установку вітряків затвердили в рекордно швидкі строки -
лише за 13 місяців.
Розробка цього проекту була узгоджена
з місцевою владою.
Протягом багатьох років вітроенергетика
у Німеччині була прибутковим бізнесом.
До 2030 року уряд Німеччини має намір
суттєво збільшити частку електроенергії
з відновлюваних джерел.
Вітряки є однією з головних складових цієї стратегії.
Але втілити в життя задумане буде не так просто,
як показує приклад сусіднього містечка Бутцбах.
У Бутцбаху процес затвердження зайняв
значно більше часу.
Тому що питання, пов'язані з охороною довкілля,
вирішити виявилося складніше, ніж очікували.
Але ми постійно спілкувалися
з жителями і політиками.
У результаті дозвіл на будівництво дали.
Але проект таки призупинили.
Сьогодні тут могли б уже обертатися лопаті вітрових турбін.
Адже дозвіл нам видали понад рік тому.
Але потім це рішення оскаржили,
і відтоді весь процес зупинився.
Ми рік чекали початку судового розгляду.
Тепер засідання призначене на січень.
Проти спорудження вітропарку виступають
місцеві екологічні активісти.
Мовляв, вітрові турбіни видають низькочастотний шум,
непомітний для людського вуха і все ж шкідливий.
Ми потерпаємо від безсоння, нервозності, запаморочення,
підвищеного кров'яного тиску - і це лише деякі
зі шкідливих наслідків,
до яких призводить інфразвук.
Місцеві жителі ставляться
до вітроенергетики по-різному.
Не думаю, що це добра ідея, ставити турбіни
в горбистих районах, як тут.
Вітропарк займає надто багато місця.
Думаю, що це прийнятно. Якщо вони поставлять вітряки тут, на верхівках пагорбів,
то вони будуть достатньо віддалені
від населених пунктів і міст. Так буде нормально.
Уряд Німеччини хоче, щоб у майбутньому вітряки розташовувалися
на відстані не менше кілометра до найближчого житлового будинку.
Це істотно ускладнить пошук майданчиків
для будівництва вітропарків.
Цього року в Німеччині встановили
лише 150 нових вітряків -
це на 80 відсотків менше, ніж торік.
Ми застрягли в процедурах отримання дозволів,
що затягуються на роки.
Популярність вітроенергетики в суспільстві
вже не така висока, як раніше,
та й судові процеси займають занадто багато часу.
Водночас експерти зауважують:
без збільшення обсягів виробленої вітрової енергії
Німеччина навряд чи зможе досягти своїх цілей
у боротьбі з потеплінням клімату.
У Німеччині сьогодні на частку відновлюваних джерел припадає 38% енергоспоживання,
а до 2030 року планується
довести цей показник до 65%.
Більше 20% енергії вітру Німеччина тепер отримує з моря.
Вітрові парки Північного моря і Балтики налічують понад 1300 вітряків
потужністю близько 6 з половиною гігават.
Утім, струм з відновлювальних джерел енергії
поки що не такий дешевий,
як хотілося б німцям -
одна кіловат-година коштує
в середньому 30 євроцентів.
Це удвічі більше, ніж у сусідній Франції,
яка все ще забезпечується переважно електроенергією від атомних станцій.
Німеччина ж, як відомо, повністю відмовляється
від атомної електроенергії.
До того ж, рік тому у ФРН
закрили останню вугільну шахту,
що ознаменувало кінець цілої епохи.